hey good morning everybody
it's uh just about 10 o'clock and
you know i'll just let a few more people
get on i said i'd start at 10
it's about 9 59 but um you know today is
memorial day in the us
and you know it's been a quiet
session usually you know these holidays
are pretty quiet but um you know i
thought today would be a good day to do
a presentation
on close driver
you know there's a lot of
traders don't really understand
how a market is driven what drives a
market and it's important because
you know a market is either
moving or it's not moving you know in
the sense of you know sort of being
range bound or trending and
you know we all most of us you know
use indicators in some form you know i
have my own order flow-based indicators
you know other traders use
momentum-based indicators um some
traders use support resistance which you
know is
in a way of a form of an indicator
and you know there's sometimes there's
just it seems like there's
there's no one size fits all right you
can't use
um you can't use a non-trending type of
indicator
um you know in a market that's trending
right
you want to use it when it's in a
trading range right and you know you
want to use a momentum-based indicator
when the market is
trending but you know when it comes to
order flow
what really attracted me to order flow
years ago
was the ability to see what's happening
how the market is trading before
a move happens or if we're you know in a
trading range right when we're in a
trading range
the order flow that you see going
through looks very
vanilla right looks very plain you know
there's nothing special about it
but when you start to see things that
are
different right i don't say unique but
you know certain type of activity coming
into the market
you know it's coming in for a reason
right people
have thoughts of the direction of the
market and they're willing to put their
money where their mouth is
right you know small retail traders we
just don't have that ability we're too
small
but the big traders the people that
really going to move the market
do have that and you know what i want to
talk about today is how to
see that in the market so you know
before we jump in you know just a brief
disclaimer you know do understand
trading involves risk
right and risk capital is money that can
be used without um jeopardizing
your lifestyle right or your financial
security
um you know only risk apples should be
used for trading and only those with
sufficient risk capital should consider
trading
you know people are nowadays trading a
lot of
bitcoin right and unfortunately a lot of
people are doing it on margin and
they're finding out the reality
of trading when the markets only don't
go up okay so
don't uh you know don't risk your
family's money
unless you know you have other money to
to back it up with so to speak
you know and again you know past
performance not necessarily indicative
of future results all right so
you know let's jump into this um you
know the topic for today
is you know sort of a new way to analyze
order flow
you know because that's what's
fascinating about order flow you know
even though it's order flow in its sense
has been around
uh people have been training with order
flow for well over 100 years
you know 100 years ago back in the the
1920s as opposed to where we are right
now in the
2020s um you know we experienced a big
massive bull run right leading up to a
big
market crash and and depression and but
back then people were even using order
flow now
it wasn't as advanced as it is now you
know they were looking at
ticker tape scroll across the you know
literally a you know a piece of paper
coming out we've all seen those old
pictures those old movies and now it's
you know with the advent of
computers and especially personal
computers and even you know advancements
in the handphone
you know literally people are able to
get this information in the palm of
their hands
it's almost instantaneously not as it
trades because you know there is a lag
between the data coming from the
exchange to
to you but it's still very important
information okay so i'm not going to
talk about you know the beauty of order
flow we all know
we all understand you know how order
flow can help us really what i want to
jump into today is um sort of five
topics right
what type of trader are you what drives
the market
markets to trade parabolic moves day
session versus night session
so you know all of these are important
in sort of well determining if you're
going to be successful or not you know
because
ultimately as a trader it's you
right it's not necessarily you against
the market where
you know you're fighting against you
know market movement
and stuff you're sort of fighting
against yourself in a way
right um you know making the right
decision and
sort of what that comes down to are you
know some of these topics that we're
going to be talking about today so
you know what type of trader are you
okay and and there's
basically five in my opinion you know
five types of traders right there's
scalpers there's day traders intraday
swing traders
um swing traders and long-term traders
right scalper
in and out quickly you know a lot of
trades during the day
day trader a little bit slower than
you know a scalper you know a lot less
trades
intraday swing trader you know are the
the guys that are
you know looking to catch you know the
one or two big moves if there's going to
be one
in a day a swing trader you know someone
that's going to hold the position for a
few days
and a long-term trader is you know
someone's going to put their money in
the market and let it sit there
um you know for however long you know
months you know i'll say years but you
know months at least
so you have to determine what type of
trader you're going to be
myself i sort of fall in under the
scalper
um not so much the day trader in the
sense where
you know i pay low commissions
i'm happy to take a lot of trades i'm
happy to
the reason i'm happy to do that is
because i know my time is limited
okay i can't sit in front of a screen
for six hours eight hours a day
you know that a lot of people are are
you know like like when i was younger
okay i just don't have that
ability anymore um hang on a second here
okay so where are you
okay are you a scalper you like to take
a lot of trades you know if you're an
order flow trader if you read order flow
you know it's going to be in your best
interest to be
as short a term trader as far as you
know
holding a trade than a long-term trader
because
you're basing your trading decisions off
of what's happening right now whether
you get into a trade
whether you know it's based on what is
trading now
now however long you want to hold it is
another
part of the equation right you know
because
as you're reading the order flow as
you're in a position as you're in a
trade and you're reading the order flow
it's going to give you new information
should you still be in the trade should
you not be in the trade right and
in my opinion sorry what's the
difference between a scalper and day
trader is
is is partly coming down to
your take profit levels right scalpers
really quick you know
the the when there was the
um trading pit on the floor you know
there's
there were you know groups of scalpers
right there were guys literally that
would hold a
position for three seconds five seconds
um you know if it just wasn't in their
favor they'd get out
okay they weren't looking to
hold into this position you know a long
time if they could get out at a tick
that's it they're fine
um you know that that's really in the
pure sense what a scalper is
you know now people sort of lump in
scalpers and
day traders in in the same group you
know but for me you know
i would define scalper as somebody
that's much more short-term than a day
trader
okay day trader you know may get into a
trade
in the morning you know 8 45 and hold it
until
10 um you know until 10 30.
okay where's this intraday swing trader
you know may get into a trade at 9 45
and hold it until um two o'clock okay
but a day trader takes more trades than
than an intraday swing trader
you know swing trader i don't do that
anymore you know i don't like to
necessarily i don't say take the risk
but you know i don't like to sit there
at night
always checking the market and stuff you
know i hated that
um you know back when i was working i
hate getting calls that in the literally
in the middle of the night over
a position or something it's just like
you know i i i don't i don't like to
take my work home with me so to speak
um you know that's why i really wasn't
into
swing trading and you know but you know
there's good profits to be had there
it's not to say that swing trading isn't
for everybody for real for certain
people it is now long-term traders
you know it's it's you know it's funny
because when people say
you know oh this traders got you know
ice in their reins you know they tend to
be like a long-term trader
is because they're not
bothered by the intraday price swings
you know the way a day trader is or you
know an intraday
you know or even a swing trader you know
a long-term trader says yeah okay you
know i
put my position on and you know just
sort of wake me up in three months
and you know like something like that
you know but it's not like they're
they're so
cold and calculated the the way you know
as a scalper
would be a long-term trader sort of you
know has this big
macro view of the market whereas a
scalper
has you know a very very micro um
view you know most of the most of
everybody is putting in there what type
of trader there are a lot of scalpers
right
10 15 seconds um 10 to 20 seconds
yeah that's that's fine you know like
for me
when i'm scalping you know i'm looking
for that market to move based on the
order flow i'm looking for it to happen
right now right and if it's not
happening after
10 minutes you know i find those for me
personally those are the worst trades
that i take is the trades that
you know i get in and they immediately
start going sideways
or you know start grinding against me um
you know that's where
being a scalper you understand that you
know time is of the essence and if the
market doesn't move
um in your favor it's probably not going
to make that move
all right so the second part that i want
to talk about is sort of what drives the
markets
okay now obviously all of us are our
retail traders
in the past i used to be in a different
category you know i used to be an
institutional side
but you know since 2013
i've been on the retail side and again
it doesn't matter whether you're a
retail trader trading
one lot or a 50 lot if you're a retail
trader you're a retail trader
size doesn't matter when you start
talking about the different types of
traders
you know the really big traders are sort
of the traders
you never hear of yeah you know you you
read about you know these
um hedge fund guys and all that but
really the biggest traders are are what
they call the real money traders
okay you know people like um you know
the sovereign wealth funds the
um you know the real money accounts
right the pension funds
you know not these hot shot hedge fund
traders yeah you know
they're the ones that oh you see oh this
guy made uh
two billion dollars well a lot of it
comes from fees
um you know obviously their performance
is also tied to their their payoff but
you know honestly you got five billion
dollars on a management and
you know if you perform well you can get
a big payday
um you know it's those aren't those are
big traders but in my mind those are not
the biggest traders right the biggest
traders and i'll give you
a sense of size
um you know i've seen the orders that
are generated by um you know a central
bank
in hong kong okay and i've seen their
roles at s p roll time
okay and it's massive right you don't
think about how big it is
um you know as a retail trader but you
just sort of sit back and you're like
wow
um you know you're talking in the tens
of thousands
of position in the big s ps okay and
put that in relation to um
minis right it was the ratio is five to
one you know they're they're rolling
70 000 big s ps
you know that's what 5 to 1 seventy
thousand
is to do the math it's like three
hundred thousand minis a position that
they have on
right and you know so they're not really
so concerned with you know the little
price fluctuations during the day
that's why i say you know these
long-term traders guys that just sort of
dig in and hold it forever you know
there's a lot of reasons why they would
hold it forever
not forever but you know hold up for a
long time you know they they have to
have a court position and they just sort
of trade around it
um you know to me those are the big the
big
traders right the big pension funds that
are have
you know tens and 20 billions of dollars
under management you don't hear about
those hotshot traders at
um you know the california retirement
fund or something like that right you
don't you don't hear about them i mean
they make very good money obviously
those big hedge funds
those big real money accounts
get paid a lot of money because you know
if they don't they just jump to a hedge
fund
but you don't hear about them the way
you hear about hedge fund traders but
you know those are really the the the
big
accounts and those are the ones that
really drive the market you know in the
short term a hedge fund yes it can drive
the market
um but really what sort of drives the
market are
you know these real money accounts okay
and and people don't really talk about
them
but when you talk about real money
accounts it goes
it's just so much bigger than you know
what what you see in an individual hedge
fund
um but at the same time everything that
everybody trades
shows up in the market and
if you know what to look for then yeah
you can see it
now you know this is where it starts to
get interesting is because
they don't always just trade during the
us day session
you know a lot of these really big
real money accounts are based overseas
okay so sometimes they're going to be
active
when the markets are not trading during
the u.s
hours um you know this question there
chris
asks um you know the ones that make up
the commitment of traders yeah they they
do show up in the commitment of traders
as you know an institutional
thing it doesn't i don't think they have
i haven't looked at it recently
i know a few years ago they made some
changes to the commitment of traders but
yeah it does
show up in the cot the commitment of
traders um you know their activity
you know with commitment traders once
you get over you know exchanges have
limits that a
entity can have on right um position the
limits
and you know once you get above a
certain limit then you have to disclose
that
okay you have to file paperwork with the
exchange and not everybody can
you know i know like for example like
um grains right they have a 5 000
contract limit for
corn wheat soybeans etc and
hedge funds generally can't get above
that limit
you know they get above that limit they
start getting notifications and
you know their broker has their the
prime broker because
they're so big they use a prime broker
you know generally has to you know has
to get them out of that trade if they
don't get out of it because
you know there will be fines and people
understand that oh you know if a
customer violates things you know
it's up to the customer to get out no
the broker will get them out because if
the broker doesn't
take care of the issue the broker then
starts running into issues with
the exchange right and you know worst
case scenario
they can lose access to the exchange i
know that you know when i was at
j.p morgan um the osaka exchange
you know where they trade the nikai in
japan um
you know jp morgan we would give clients
access to the exchange big um you know
other trading firms can you know we're
our customer and they would they would
route through the jpmorgan
infrastructure
and we would have you know there was
every once in a while we'll get a call
from the exchange saying you know
what's going on we're like you know on
our end we don't know it's you know what
what's
what's going on per se but they say why
are you entering so many orders and
canceling them so quickly
and you know what what these prop firms
would do is you know they have these
algo
and you know as literally as soon as the
window opens up for pre
market you know entering the orders as
early as you can they would have this
program that would just shoot in orders
at every price level
up and down the price letter so they'd
be first in queue right so when the
market opens
you know being first in queue you know
it's a first in first stop being
the best bid at every price level or
close to the best bid at every price
level on the way down
you know is going to be in your favor
especially when you're trying to scalp
the market so you know they would enter
all these orders
you know just barrage you know just
inundate the system
you know because it would generate a lot
of ticket numbers from the exchange and
sometimes you know these exchanges
too much activity cause it causes it to
slow down but
they would um cancel you know the ones
that weren't
first in line they would cancel you know
re-enter orders and you know the
exchange would just be like hey you know
what
this is causing a problem stress on our
system stop it
and you know so the broker jp morgan
you know tell the customer stop doing
that you know because
if you don't then the exchange is going
to
put saying you know i'll say sanctions
but you know they're going to revoke our
access
ultimately if you keep playing these
games and if you don't stop playing the
games then
we're going to kick you out as a
customer basically so you know even
though there's nothing happening on our
end on the trading desk you know it's
happening
someplace else so you know these big
traders
are much different than retail traders
now
the the thing
is you know with with markets especially
when it comes to order flow right before
i start jumping into some of these order
flow
things please understand right there's
more than just
e-minis and and q okay um you know
i know that that's the market that most
people are interested in is because of
the low margins
and obviously now you got the micro
contracts but
you know honestly if you're trading
something because it has low margins per
say um
that itself is probably not the best
reason to trade that market
you know you should trade a market that
in my opinion is
easy to trade right i mean why trade
something that you're sort of forced to
trade
because you're restricted by you know
the amount of money in your account
and you know i i get the whole thing of
i don't have a lot of money to trade
um you know you can trade obviously now
the micros
which is a lot less but you know
make sure you have enough money in your
account to trade look at other markets
at least because you know
the thing with e-minis and nq is the
type of players that are in there
are obviously very sophisticated
more so than the retail trading crowd
you know now that's not to say that
everyone in the retail trading crowd is
not sophisticated i've seen some very
sophisticated um trading systems but
you know you i just feel like you're
sort of putting yourself at a
disadvantage
because there's so much algo activity
that happens in
e-minis and nq that
for a lot of people you know they can't
handle these
quick moves now people say well nq is
more volatile than
than es but you know there's a ratio you
know
e-minis move two ticks and q moves ten
ticks people say well
and q is such a bigger um
thing so it's
you know just bear that in mind okay
just just bear that in mind that there's
many other markets
and the reason i talk about that is
because you know people
sort of put themselves at a disadvantage
when it comes to
trading the market because you know they
don't necessarily understand
what they're doing per se um
and i just feel that there's so many
other markets that follow order flow
that aren't driven that don't have that
algorithmic activity
um that don't have that hot money in
terms of hedge funds in and out of the
market
that if you're going to trade with order
flow it's really
in my opinion sometimes better just to
stick to markets that
are really sort of still true to their
roots in the sense of
you know they have big commercial
participation commercial participation
leads to support and resistance levels
holding much better
right and you know when you have sport
resistance holding better
then it's a bit easier to read the
market not just necessarily read the
order flow yeah it makes reading the
order flow
a lot better but you know the moves
seem easier to find okay so
you know if you were to ask me what the
top
non-equity markets are right
i would say um
you know obviously the currencies right
and that should be an easy one
right now obviously the currency futures
are related to the cash market but you
know they follow it pretty well
you know there's there's you know
honestly you know the big banks are more
involved
in the cash market than than the futures
market although
they do trade a lot in in the futures
market but you know really the majority
of their activity is in the cash market
the grain market is a great market to
trade um
and it's if someone were to put a gun to
my head and say
yeah you got to trade and you got to
make money i wouldn't trade
e-minis or nq you know i would trade one
of the grain markets
okay now i have my the ones that i like
right soy meal
um you know to a certain extent wheat
you know corn now is is much more active
um you know in the past corn was a very
boring market but now obviously with the
inflation you know hitting the grain
markets
you know corn is getting some nice
movements soybeans is a little bit more
volatile than
um you know wheat or corn but that's
also a nice market
um yeah crude okay you know nat gas okay
gold and silver yeah i mean they could
be volatile at times
um but you know they're also nice
markets there's a lot of nice markets
buns
buns is a terrific market to trade
especially if you're in
you're in europe um
you know because of the trading hours
and you know it's 10 euros a tick it
trades and
it's decimalized um unlike the bonds are
still in 30 seconds
it it's there's a lot of nice markets
out there beyond just
equity indices okay just bear that in
mind i'm not
saying you have to trade those or look
at them but you know i just find those
those markets tend to move
better in my opinion um you know some of
the moves are
are much cleaner so all right let's sort
of jump into
the order flow here um just give me a
second here
what chart do i want to look at make
sure i got the right chart up uh
all right so just bear with me so
what do i got here this is
british pounds okay oh we'll start with
um
british bound here just so this is this
is a footprint chart okay
um what's going on here with my system
hang on i had to replace my mouse
so it's like if you hear something very
clicky that's my mouse
so this is this morning
let's give it a second here all right so
obviously today
very very quiet day in the markets right
it's a holiday
okay and you know there really wasn't
much movement
in the market this is a british pound
okay um
anyway okay well here there's just a
nice move that just happened
in the british pound it just it shot up
it was at 141.85 all the way up to
215 right it's a nice parabolic moves
and you know i'll talk about that
parabolic moves in a minute but
just go forward here
now you know i bought bitcoin last year
okay
i bought it when it was in the teens all
right i didn't think it would go up to
40 50 60 000 this year
i bought it because i thought it'd go
you know back up to the 20s and
you know i didn't expect the big move up
now was i lucky or was i smart
well i was smart to buy it in the sense
that you know i thought it was going to
go up i did not expect it to go up into
the 40s or 50s
so quickly but so i was lucky in that
sense now
when you see a move like this right
this move look at that it's literally a
vertical move straight up
this is a one minute chart on british
pounds all right this just happened
okay and you know people say wow you
know
people that were buying in here you say
well you know they must have been lucky
right because to catch that move now
this is a move right if you were to look
at
what's happening here right you know
this was your
basically your range was like this right
this was basically your range you know
85 people say well you know
you're breaking out i mean honestly if
you go back earlier we were above there
now do you think the people that were
buying here you know just got lucky
or something you know but honestly the
activity that's going to
precipitate this move up this straight
move
up is coming in in here
right it's not just you know people
decide oh you know i'm gonna put this
position on and you know
come hell or high water you know they're
gonna take profit you know
there's the big traders you know that's
why i spent some time talking about the
really big traders
are the ones that have access to
information
that you and i just don't have we're
never going to have um
you know whether it's you know they got
a friend that works in a central bank or
you know
knows something about policy that's
going to come out i don't really care
you know really what i'm looking for as
a trader
is you know is it going to happen you
know is this move
going to give me some nice
potential okay now if you were to look
at the order flow
honestly it it what you're seeing in
here is
very little flow honestly you see two
price levels right that's coming in
you know at nine fifty only put a cross
hairs on here so it's a little easier to
see
okay right here right let me make it a
little
thicker uh across here
so it's a little easier to see
okay here here here here here here okay
now look at this market right it just
seems to be
fairly quiet you know you're literally
trading the bid
in the offer that's it you know going on
right here trading the bid in the offer
bid the offer you know one tick below a
couple ticks up
a bit off for a bit off for a bit offer
it's a one price level
right 140 177 you know you would go
77 bit at 78 or 77 bid at 76 right it
would just trade that one price level
right
you know there's you look at it and say
well what's the point of using order
flow it's not moving
well it starts to move here right you
start seeing some activity come in
okay right in here in here
in here in here
in here in here all right you start the
market is picking up some signs of life
now what are some of the clues
obviously you know the imbalances are
one
obviously the volume picks up you know
back in here
you know you're trading when it's just
dead in the water you know other than
this bar that trades 324 contracts
what do you got in here a whole lot of
nothing you know
12 36 13 21 14 4 16 40 10 25
65 41 10 right now it starts picking up
a hundred okay 25 that's nothing well
here was 75
113 just 25 you know it's nothing and
188 372
523 okay so it's activity is
really really picking up right and
then boom the market pops from basically
the
you know the 90 area all the way up into
you know nearly you know into new highs
and we didn't hit 20 yet
but it went all the way up to 18 right
that's
what is that a 28 tick move when
before your whole range was basically
you know what 80 86 to
66 right so you just double that entire
range in
about five minutes okay but the signs
were there
right if you know what you're going to
be looking for in the order flow now
you know some of the clues are you know
pretty obvious in the order fill but
you're seeing in here right if you're
looking at the max and min deltas right
you've got a lot of
very little buying right in terms of max
delta max delta is
what uh um
you know what the strongest delta was
for a bar
okay so you've seen zero one zero so you
know it's it's nothing
right and it's just all min delta even
though it's not much it's minus 13 minus
minus 13. but you don't have that big
strong positive delta
in terms of max delta then it says of
sudden flips in here
right you got no selling right zero
and this one is kind of mixed then this
one is zero this one's one
right and this max delta is 43 final
delta is 41
19 and 19 max delta 19 final delta 19
69 max delta
final delta is 69. right obviously
you've got imbalances
okay imbalance and balance and balance
so you know that there's
aggressive buyers are stepping in now
okay so
you add in what's happening in the max
deltas the pickup in volume
um sorry the internal deltas max and min
delta
the imbalances obviously the final delta
you start picking things up now the
problem is for a lot of
traders it's hard to pick that up
right unless you got a lot of experience
you know looking at the chart
you know in watching order flow that you
can sort of you know see how it it
really picked up now
you know people say well earlier you got
a lot of max and min deltas you know
going back and forth here yeah
but you got no volume all right 10
25 65 41 10.
you know that's not very strong
you know you need you want to see volume
excuse me you can drink some water here
sorry um you know you need to see that
that volume really
really pick up for the market to move
right because you know market's not
going to move unless it has someone
moving it right it's just not natural
gravity in in the sense of
moving up or or pulling something right
it needs that
impetus and you know remember
right if you sort of scrunch in this
chart
this market was sort of on a you know a
bit on
a on a downtrend right we were
giving you a look at this right we were
here at
let's change this crosshair uh
is it white should be black
right we were trading here at 99 you
know just under
142.00 working our way down
you got a a lower high lower low
lower high not necessarily lower low but
then it just stopped and reversed and
went
when parabolic right went straight up
okay
and that's where reading what's
happening in the order flows is going to
help you
um you know catch those moves right
those are those moves that you know
as a trader you know you want to have
i mean ideally i mean yeah you know it's
nice to
um you know catch the the move you know
the
the intraday moves you know because not
all moves go
parabolic like literally what just
happened here right a lot of times
you're looking at these these smaller
moves down here
um you know some sideways activity in
here
and you know catching that parabolic
move you know small move up you know
on a holiday it's tough right as a
trader
right you know you as a scalper that's
why i prefer to scalp
because i know that
i'm not necessarily looking right now
for these big moves unless
a scalp turns into a longer term trade
and how do you turn a scalp into a
longer term trade is
by understanding the order flow right
what's going through
in the order flow and there's a lot of
other little clues
that are going to give you um
reasons to stay in a trade right so
being in a trade you know
picking up what's happening here right
the imbalances all that stuff the delta
the volume picking up
and you're in this trade right year long
you know we'll call it 90 right here at
this
poc okay you're in this trade trade
comes two ticks against you not even two
ticks one tick right you're along at 90.
it only trades down to 89
and immediately shoots back up okay so
you're in the trade
what are you going to be looking at for
signs of staying in a trade staying in a
in a move
especially if it's you know you don't
know if it's going to go parabolic or if
it's just going to go up here
and then sort of turn around and come
back down well you want to be looking at
a few things one
obviously is where the point of controls
come in right
are we going higher in the points of
controls right do we have
obviously you know you want to see green
bars right if you're long
right that's just a basic one right if
you're getting long
and the next thing you see is a bunch of
red bars chances are it's not going to
work out that's just
that's nothing fancy that's just common
sense right um
but if point of controls are moving
higher as well
that's a that's a good sign because the
market is facilitating trade
at higher price levels which is what you
want to see okay you want to see the
markets go
up with higher volume at new levels
right you don't want to see the market
just or poke higher but then
come off and start trading heavier
volume at lower levels right that's not
a good sign
now you also want to see obviously
you want to see positive delta right but
you can say oh this bar has got
negative delta minus 33 that's that's
bearish isn't it
all right or this green bar has got
negative delta isn't that bearish
because it's negative delta the sellers
are in control well that's where
understanding what's happening in the
order flow is going to help you
just because you have a green bar with
negative delta
doesn't necessarily mean sellers are in
control it actually has
an opposite meaning it tells you
supportive buyers
are present okay i'm not gonna say in
control but they're present okay so you
got minus 33 on the delta
so that's telling me that there were
more sellers
than buyers in the bar obviously but at
the same time the bar closed higher so
somebody is bidding on this way up
okay they're basically absorbing the
selling that's coming in right we're
starting to break out right we just
broke out of 85
starting to go higher so there's sellers
you know trying to sell it back into the
range right
you have all these guys um
here right they're selling it looking
for this market to sort of come back
into this range as we're breaking out
but as we're breaking out you have
people bidding the market you know
putting bids in the market
that are literally absorbing what the
aggressive sellers
are are hit throwing at them right
that's why you have
that negative delta on these green bars
and it's very evident when you get to
this bar right here
right this 124 now the point of control
is a little bit lower
all right it's one tick lower than the
previous one overall
the trend is still up i like it when you
got green bars and
you know you're looking at a point of
control on the next bar that's lower
than the previous bar
because it's telling me the market was
trying to facilitate trade lower
but there was someone absorbing all that
activity and the market traded higher
obviously you've got buying imbalances
way on you know on the top of this bar
so people say well okay wow you have you
know a new high you got the negative
delta minus 107. yeah but the bar closed
up right so there was somebody there
absorbing it and you could see it just
by looking at the footprint right the
so even those people were selling it
here just off this high right
at the time 04 was the high people were
coming in
selling it selling it okay
and it just they could have moved it
lower because there was someone
absorbing that right you had
the absorption happening here as well
the 144 but this one is more obvious
because it just sticks out with the
negative delta
and the sellers finally gave up
right and once the sellers gave up you
know the smart traders realized the
sellers
sort of you got no more bullets left so
to speak
and the market starts moving higher
aggressive activity comes in
with those buying imbalances and boom
the market goes up to the new highs now
you know then we just sort of went
sideways i think we're closing at what
what time is it close to 12 or 10 30 i
can't remember on the holiday
um but you know right now we found that
new level and we're just sort of going
sideways again
okay so understand
you know what's happening there in the
order flow is going to help you stay in
the trade just because you got this red
this green candle up with the negative
delta
that's not a sign to get out right you
got to start looking at what's happening
in the order flow in the sense of
our points of control is going higher
what's the delta telling me right
because you could say well you know
delta's negative that's bearish well yes
and no
it's bearish that you have aggressive
selling coming in
but it's actually bullish that you got
someone absorbing all that selling
right and the markets again still
work their way up you know the
imbalances people say well you got the
selling imbalances 31 here you got the
selling imbalance that's 48
but again these are on markets that
close higher
right bars that close higher so i know
that
it's someone absorbing it right in green
candles right
generally you're going to see buying
imbalances right up candles
generally have buying imbalances but
when you start to see
um selling imbalances on candles moving
higher
it's telling you it's a sign of
absorption people were coming in here
trying to sell it right
this yellow line right here is unchanged
okay so
you know people were trying to sell it
as we were breaking out of the 85 area
then
back up but unchanged they're trying to
sell it to get it back into
the range that we just were but you have
strong
passive buying and that's the you know
when you understand
the difference between passive buying
and aggressive buying and where it comes
in
and where it's important you know that's
what's going to help you as a trader
right because if you're breaking out to
new levels
okay and you just see aggressive buying
okay you know maybe it's fomo
you know people say oh you know we're
making new highs um
i got to get involved right just like
everyone when bitcoin was at 62 000
oh or 62 000 you know new highs i got i
got to buy more
and you know it's easy to fall into that
trap but when you see
this right when you see the support of
buying
coming in as you're breaking out whether
to new highs
or you know of a range when you see
support
people saying you know who's really
doing the support of buying
right do they think it's the retail
traders
you know the bigger traders you know
oftentimes it's
the bigger traders because they're doing
a combination
right they're not necessarily just
lifting the offers they're also working
bids
because they want to get a good price
right a lot of times retail traders are
just
you know i mean retail traders do work
bids
and offers but it's small size compared
to the big traders right then that's why
i say you got to understand
you know i said the real money accounts
if we're breaking out of a range like
today okay today was again it is a quiet
day we're sort of breaking out of this
range i'm not saying you know real money
guys are coming in but you know if we're
breaking out of
a yearly range or something you see that
type of activity
right again they're they're saying okay
we're starting to break out we're
starting to move okay they'll work
bids right they'll lift offers you know
they'll split it up i mean
these execution algos nowadays are very
sophisticated
um you know what used to take a
execution trader to do
that they'll go you just type it in and
it knows exactly what to do it's going
to work bids it's going to lift offers
as the market starts moving higher it's
going to raise its bids
it's going to lift some more offers
again it's in a sense it's
moving the market but trying not to
right that's why you see a lot more
volume traded here on on these bids you
know the 31
um you know the 42 just you know even in
here the 124
the 48 to 19 to 27. you know they're
they're
feeding it into the market so to speak
without trying to necessarily lift the
offers but if the market starts moving
then yeah it'll get aggressive
um
you know someone's asking you are the
this is just the high and the low all
right this
right now this this line here this green
line this dotted line is the
high of the day right that's why i see
it keeps changing i don't have
unfinished auctions turned on
right now this line here is the um
opening price this red line down here is
the low of the day
okay case you're wondering um
so you know that sort of takes me on to
the next again you know i was
seeing that this parabolic move here in
the british pound today it was just very
apt right it came right as
you know we started this webinar because
you know understanding
the different types of moves right the
parabolic moves you have to realize
again this is why when it comes to
trading
certain markets
you got to understand you know can the
market have a straight up and down move
generally like
to me that that british pound move was
you know what i would consider
the parabolic move right it's just
literally
shot straight up here right i mean
people say well you know it's not really
a parabolic move
um yeah to me that's a parabolic move
you know if you look you know
when people talk about it but again at
the same time you know your market
has to have that ability to do it now
people say well nasdaq you know it's
very volatile it should be able to do it
yes and no it has these quick moves
but oftentimes it reverts it right back
in the next couple of bars you know
it's kind of a frustrating market to
trade in that sense that's why
you know grain markets and some of these
other markets that
really in my opinion follow supply and
demand a lot better than the equity
markets
are better for trading okay so
um before i get to the day or night
sessions let's sort of go back and
um well talk about a couple of the
markets real quick
now you know another market that's
that's really popular with
i don't say with the kids nowadays um
well
okay that's wheat let's talk about uh
i don't know um
uh let's take a look at silver okay
because you know silver is
you know one of these markets that you
know
a lot of people are interested in
nowadays partly because of the whole you
know
gme and all that stuff that that's been
happening now
you know is it a market that can go
parabolic and for me when i talk about
parabolic i'm not necessarily talking
um you know on a daily basis right again
you know i said
i'm more into um scalping
you know i'm a much shorter term trader
than than normal
um then sorry that normal than i used to
be in the past right
in the past i used to be willing to hold
positions
a lot longer than i am now so
you know last night in in silver i think
there was a
let me just throw a silver chart in here
really quick
uh let's go here or just over here and
just
okay so there's some moves like here
right a nice literally
a nice straight up move let's go back to
the night session because that sort of
leads into what i want to talk about
next
um the the night session okay
because you know i realize a lot of
people
live overseas or you know they have jobs
during the day
where you know they can't necessarily
um you know trade the markets
during the day session right which is
you know where people think you know a
lot of the activity is you know the best
activity is going to be happening
during the day session well you get a
lot of movements at night and when
you're a small retail trader trading
three lots five lots you can trade the
night session
pretty easily okay so
here you got this one bar right it went
from 2808 all the way up to
um 28 25 you know i'm not going to say
it's a parabolic move but you know these
are those bars that
you know as a trader you like to get
unfortunately this is the type of bar
that you take
it's going to take out your take profit
you know pretty much in in the same bar
um
but if you're watching the order flow in
here you can see the clues
right there's clues to be had as a
trader
in the order flow okay this part here is
garbage right
honestly there's nothing to be had here
okay if you're reading the order flow
and
as a young trader i'll say when i was
first trying to read order flow many
many years ago
these bars would always drive me up the
wall
right but even when you see that there
are clues in here if you're watching the
delta but
bars that trade three contracts five
contracts eight contracts aren't going
to give you much to go off of
you really need a little bit more volume
and when the volume starts to pick up
here 128
67 65 it's giving you a clue
okay we're at these highs come off a
little bit right and then boom you just
shoot straight up right that's the bar
that you love to take as a trader
right the big wide ranging bar straight
up
right but you had plenty of opportunity
to buy in here
11 10 09 markets coming down
right but the clues were in here
early two bars earlier right this blue
little blue up arrow is actually the
signal telling you to
get long but it's based off what's
happening
in these earlier bars right you're
seeing imbalances
right you're seeing nice strong positive
delta
nice healthy volume
excuse me and the market boom
pops straight up all right popped up the
new highs sort of come off a little bit
and then boom you know just went made
that big big move up that you know
as a trader those are those bars that
you know you you want to
um participate in right and that's
happening
in the night session okay let's just go
back
again since we're talking about the
night session um
what day is 20 i don't have a calendar
in front of me um
go back i remember
sort of the 27th into the 28th the night
right
when we're on 2790 or something where
was that here about
make sure i got the right day here
20 oh may 27
28 is what i'm looking at um
okay right in here okay
we're at these highs of the days nothing
really super exciting going on in here
right
you see just average volume right now
this is at one in the morning
okay when europe is opening up
but you see volume is starting to pick
up okay
volume you know you're seeing some bars
you know 74 you know you're at the high
if you're at the high of the day you
want to see some
decent volume right though sort of the
worst thing that you can happen
is you get up to the high of the day and
volume just really dries up right yeah
at the end of the day you should be
attracting some sort of
new buying or selling and if
nobody's interested in participating at
the high chances are that high's not
going to hold right it's probably going
to come off
and come off pretty sharply
so you can start seeing things in here
in the order flow right
um you're at this high here 55 right the
volume here was
as you're breaking this new high 83
that's what you like to see
two bars later it's 74 okay then it just
goes very quiet
29 13 20 17 21 okay then it starts
picking up 55
made a new high by two ticks okay then
and then 48 you know okay
it's decent volume
okay it's a little bit above average
because you know your average is
probably around
30 contracts well you're at 48.
you know 42 okay but what do you start
seeing right you start seeing points of
controls
migrating lower okay you start seeing
obviously
these negative deltas minus 13 minus 24
you're seeing very small positive deltas
now you're at your high of the day
okay remember you got to think you know
there's an order flow based trader you
got to be thinking well what's going on
okay we're at a high of the day are we
going higher or we're going to come off
right and the sign that we're probably
not going higher
is you don't see much aggressive buying
coming in five
seven one one you know then you got
negative deltas minus six
minus four minus fourteen that's not a
good sign
okay so you're at the house you gotta be
looking you now you're sort of
your thought process should be like well
okay we're at the highs of the day up
here right that's this green line
but new buyers aren't being attracted
into this market okay
and so you guys start looking for the
negative signs so this bar obviously got
negative delta minus 13
minus 24. zero buying in the sense of
max delta not say that's no buying at
all it's just
no not aggressive buying going going
through the market okay it's just
zero and zero right at no point where
the aggressive buyer is in control
as you just made that new high okay so
again that's another
negative sign the min deltas we're close
to the min delta numbers minus 25
and we close at minus 24 minus 17 we
close at minus 13.
okay but again really one of the big
clues is we're at the high
we're sort of just going sideways but
you got
very little aggressive buying right
people aren't
fomo into the market so to speak okay so
what do you think the market is going to
do it's not going to go higher so
chances are it's going to go lower
and yeah it does right if it's not the
big move but again
what type of trader are you are you a
scalper or
you know a day you know a day trader or
intraday swing trader
you're getting short there's plenty of
opportunity to be getting short in here
right at this level 85 86 85 and a half
even in here 83 and a half
this is 83 83 and a half 84 in here you
got
this is five minutes to get short
okay then it starts moving down
right you have plenty of opportunity to
get short so
you know i know people think well i'm
gonna be a scalper i'm gonna
it's gotta i'm gonna be in and out very
quick you
now you're trading silver in the night
session okay
moves take a little sometimes a little
bit longer than normal
but if you're short you're still going
in your favor
right this time it's a little bit sloppy
order flow in the sense that yes point
of controls are
migrating lower delta's kind of mixed
these deltas honestly are kind of small
okay
minus five two three but that's good if
you're short right because if it was
plus 20
plus 30 you'd be seeing the market in my
opinion reverse and start going higher
all right and then just sort of go
sideways in these two bars
then you get that push back down to this
yellow line
um so you know it's a move from you know
85 and a half 86
or even you know 83 84
down into the 70s right and it just sort
of grinds
and grinds in the air for me personally
the opening price
acts as a magnet right if we're coming
down from above
we hit it i expect the market to sort of
rotate around it or if we're coming up
from below
um you know i'd expect the market to um
also hang around that at that area so
it's you know
another market really quick you know
it's really
one of my i say one of my favorites but
again it's it's not a a glamorous market
for
a lot of traders in the sense that um
you know oh
what do you trade i i trade nasdaq or i
trade e-minis
but it's soy meal okay um
let's give you a perfect example let's
go back a few days
and it's closed today usually on these
public holidays it's closed
but on the 26th there was this brilliant
move
up um it was the 26th
where are we here what day
us 27th this way um
okay this red line is the is the low of
the day here okay
right in here right what you're seeing
in this order flow
is very bullish if you know what to look
for now we're at the lows of the day you
know people's
you know it's i always say when i'm at
the lows i'm not trying to pick a low
but if the order flows it seems to be
changing um
from bearish to bullish yeah i'm going
to be looking to get long i'm not
necessarily looking to get short
because i already know when you're at
the low of the day the order flow is
bearish right but i'm sort of looking
always for that that change in the order
flow and it's starting to come in here
right and so remember what i was talking
about
what's happening in the max and min
deltas okay
so obviously this bar
okay let's just take it back a little
bit here so the low of the day is here
you see some buying coming in here right
this market is it's
trying to move higher right you're
seeing
zero you know very small min deltas the
selling seemed to have dried up right
minus one
minus eight zero zero this is the min
delta so let's tell me the aggressive
selling was was kind of weak you know
after we made this low even here minus 2
minus 13 then minus 1 minus 8 minus
0 0 right then it's mostly max deltas 98
and closed at 91 74 equals 64 107 close
at 106.
24. okay close at 4. with 27 close at 23
54 32. it looks like it's it's trying to
move
but then it doesn't happen right the
bind just dried up and you went zero
one on the max deltas and it's all min
deltas minus 41 minus 111.
right this bar closes at minus 109. then
this bar is kind of mixed right it's got
a nice positive delta but it's also got
the min delta
here we've got min delta minus 14 and
positive 25 again another mixed bar
closed minus nine then this red bar
it's minus 55 which is the min delta the
final delta is minus 55 but
max delta zero okay that's that looks
like a
prototypical bearish bar right but then
as so happens with order flow it changes
right that's what traders do
right they make decisions right and it
shows up in the order flow
now you see here it's minus five on the
min delta
right so where's your selling it's gone
right max delta's
75 we close at 64 in the max delta
right then the next bar minus three
max delta is 42 final delta is 31
okay so i know that it's changing
in here in the order flow it's gone from
you know this was bullish order flow but
it couldn't make that move
then you had some bearish order flow and
now we're back to bullish order flow
right so if you're a bullish order flow
what direction you're going to be
looking to trade in right you're going
to be looking to trade in on the long
side
right and then it starts building up in
here right
so even if you're not convinced yet in
here i say well yeah you know what
it was bullish it went bearish now it's
back to bullish i want to give it
another chance
you you can okay you don't have to get
long right away
watch the order flow okay and by
watching the max admin deltas
look at this this bars from 916 to
min delta's 0 minus 27 zero zero zero
zero zero zero minus one but zero zero
zero zero zero zero
right the max delta relative to the
final delta is 22
closed at 19. 18 close at 18.
63 close sorry 64. max delta close at
63.
52 goes to 52 we're closing on our
max delta numbers or very very close to
it
37 21 17 and 15 25 10
16 and 7 right 63 and 61.
all right but then look at that move
right so move from well
from in here 379 and a half but you know
say you weren't convinced yet in here
you know like i want to give some more
time you know i want to be sure
you know after this big stretch from 909
to
917 you should be convinced that there's
buying in the market already again it's
not trying to predict
that you know we're going to come down
into the 378 379 area then we're going
to rally
no it's the order flows telling you that
this market
is primed to rally and it goes from you
know even in here 379
and a half all the way up didn't make a
new high but
it got all the way up in here to
you know almost 389 you know that's a
soy meal it's ten dollars a tick okay
379 to 380 is 50 dollars right 380 381
is a hundred dollars
200 300 400
500 seven 600
dollars eight hundred dollars i'm not
saying you'd sell at 3.89 but you were
caught this move up and where is the
real bearish order flow coming
in it's after you hit 389 but it's
coming in you know 387
388 you can start i mean obviously you
can start seeing it in here
but catching this move even catching two
points three points
you know even just catching it from here
you know 380 right in here
the 380 two and a half even here
383 you know
what is it when i say 380 to
383 that's a 300 move right
people are just
these are markets people aren't just
even paying attention to right so that's
why i talk about
these markets that um
yeah they don't understand so you know i
talked a lot about reading these order
flows right
and day session and night session
obviously is a big thing so
what i want to get into now is is the
this new tool that we have to recognize
that in
what's trading um in the order flow
right this is the new indicator that i
got
it's called the flows traders let's find
my freaking screen here
um it flows driver rather right and
you know when you see these charts okay
right with the blue arrows the red
arrows
it's this is the flow's driver okay
and you know there's different settings
and again that's why i say you know
understand what type of trader you are
your close driver
is not for somebody that's um
a swing trader right it's not for
if you find yourself as a long-term
trader swing trader or even intraday
swing trader
this is not for you i'll be honest with
you so don't waste your time
but if you're a scalper or a day trader
right you're going to find this tool
very helpful right very
a big addition to your trading okay and
you know when when we created it again
you know this was not something that's
uh go back to the british pound
that i necessarily wanted to release
but you know this is something that
we've been working on and
the last couple of weeks i've been
sharing it with a few
uh other traders and they've been
interested in it so you know i sort of
put this together for you guys today and
if it's something that you'd be
interested in
especially if you're a scalper right
and you know the settings are very
simple
okay so you know there's
it's just this right the main setting is
going to be the balance the balance
strength
you know swing filter whether you want
to look for swings or longer term trades
or not um you know independent type
markets
delta analysis sort of equality in the
order flow
and i purposely kept it simple right we
put in
a lot of that analysis that i just
talked about is already inside
the algo right so really all you're
trying to
adjust based on your market is balance
balance strength you know whether or not
you want to use a swing filter
but you can see those moves right those
nice big parabolic moves up now you know
this is just a gift
right as a trader you know this people
ask you know what what's the best type
of
chart to look at you know is it a time
based chart or a tick based chart or a
range based chart
it really depends on you but honestly if
you are trading a
range based chart by the time these
moves happen
your let's go to a range based chart um
i don't know let's choose the eight
range i used to look a lot at eight
range charts on the euro currency
you in my opinion are
going to be missing out on a lot of the
moves because
range based chart the bars form you know
as the range keeps
growing you know it keeps expanding so
to speak you know you put in those many
ticks and then it forms a new bar and a
new bar and sometimes you
i just found myself especially when i
used to use a range bar
sort of what got me off range bars is i
used to trade a lot of um
mini dao and for a range bar when a
market
is moving very fast i just found myself
finding
you know getting into trades a little
bit later than normal at least with
a time-based chart you know it sort of
gives me a better
grasp on getting in and and getting out
right because if you're watching the
bars and trying to watch the order flow
but the order flows just
happening super duper fast it's it's
it's um you know it's just going to be a
bit difficult
right because on a range based chart
you're looking at
four or five bars by the time you get in
that's just my own opinion
but again if you're trading slower
markets it's probably not going to be
that big an issue
you know so that's all what i was just
talking about with reading what's
happening in the order flow
and catching those moves because there's
always signs right
as a big trader they're always thinking
of how can they get in
without moving the market right they
don't want to move the market to
tip their hand about what they're going
to do so they're trying to finesse their
their way
basically basically into the market okay
now i'll give you an example let's take
a look at gold
okay gold is a nice
market to trade it moves um
it moves a lot you know there's a lot of
price movements
up and down now again you know you can
see here it's calculating just give it a
second to come up
okay so the default settings
of flows driver is it's pretty simple
whoops here it is there's a footprint
chart
again you know if you want to look first
swing movements you would enable the
swing filter
okay i have it disabled because again if
i your intraday trader or your scalper
you don't want to wait for swings you
know meaning a recent swing high or
swing low
delta and else analysis if you want the
bar
to have confirming delta meaning a up
candle
you'd have positive delta or a down
candle red candle you'd need negative
delta
tight markets are for
specifically for markets that trade in
small ranges right like for example
you know this is a small range like if
you're trading night session you'd want
to keep it on
tight markets okay and
go back to the settings
balance equality basically you want to
make sure that the
you know the order flow in the bar is is
is equal it's just a filter
what balancing quality is you don't need
to use it but really the main things
you're going to be using
is the balance and balance strength
now you could turn it off right if you
don't want to use the balance
strength and it will the algo will work
out
all the other stuff in the order flow
okay so
when you turn it off you're going to get
a lot more signals
okay and again if depending on the
market if you
are a fast trader meaning if you are a
scalper
um you you probably want to turn it off
because you know the scalper in a pure
sense is just looking for
um the next few ticks right so if for
example if you're trading on a dome
right you know you're going to be
looking okay here's you know i got a
signal here i'm going to try to buy it
on a pullback and scalp right
back in here it's a little sideways but
again it's for not
meant for every market in the sense of
turning it off
now there's some markets for example
okay here let's
uh i'll just show you right this is what
is this british pound
if i were to it's a little easier to
show me show it to you
you know the differences on a on a bar
chart than a footprint chart
because there's only so much real estate
on the chart um
on a footprint chart so again so this is
with the
balance turned off right so when you
turn off the balance it doesn't matter
what the strength is because it's not
going to
read the balance strength so basically
this is like
if i were to turn everything off here
all right tight markets balanced
equality well actually
keep type markets on but balance
equality balance strength
balance disabled okay that's about as
free as you can go
okay you can see there's a lot more
signals right now you're seeing some
cell signals in there
um what do you got you know you got some
buy signals here
but you know you can see right it's
catching the move down
these little moves up you know we all
want to catch these
moves like this right but not all
markets
have the capability to make moves like
that
right but again this is eight o'clock at
night on a sunday
weekend night right but there's still
movements right i mean
this is the part that kills me people
say no i can only trade nasdaq and i
only traded during the day well there's
so many other markets to trade
at different times i mean look at this
you know you're talking a move from 86
all the way up to 98. you know that's
that's 10 ticks in the british pound
sunday night all right
you know during the day you're going to
get a lot more signals right that's why
i say i talk about the night session
let's just go back
the night session right this is the 20
friday or thursday night into friday
morning
you don't have these algos messing
around with you you know that you see
during the day
i mean look at that that's a nice move
down okay
yeah okay you get stopped out on a
couple trades there
then you catch this nice move back up
right so whatever you lost on these
trades you're getting back there
right but again this is with the setting
turned as low as possible
now people say well why would you turn
the setting as low as possible well
there's going to be some markets for
example
like ultra bonds ultra bonds fantastic
market to trade
margin is a bit high relative to
other markets but look at that
you're talking a move from this is your
signal here
right the 12 area 11 you know anywhere
between 10 to 12
all the way up into the 20s right that's
30 dollars a tick all right ultra bonds
this was friday during the day yeah a
couple small scalps here and there
but then you catch that nice overall
trend
all right nothing happening in the night
session this was the day before right
this is what the settings turn basically
as
low as possible right
nice moves down a little move up a
little move down
okay this one probably stopped you out
but again depending on how your scout if
you're a scalper or short-term trader
you can catch a lot of this activity
that's going on
right we'll say well you know there's
not much of a move here well you just
had that
massive drop from you know the 20 area
down to you know down to 10 almost
immediately
or even down to o5 in here or even where
you're getting these buy signals
now those are those moves that you want
to catch um
yeah let's take a look at other markets
um i don't know uh
i think only dax well yeah i think it'll
be a decks
dax is an interesting market you know
it's a market that's got a lot of price
activity um
you know there's a big drop from you
know
this area this is where you you earn
your keep as a
as a trader right you're getting those
small scalps getting you know
the little move down the move up to move
down to move down
you know you the the break even small
loss covered it in here
you know a little move up and then the
massive move down
like that right that's what you want as
a trader right and again this is with
this is at it's very basic level right
this is about as low as you can get on
the settings
pretty much everything turned off except
tight markets
but on a market like nas dax it's not
going to matter
it's you know basically gonna get the
same
same signals right
buns all right since we're in germany
and
in europe how does it look here on the
bones i don't look
this morning on the buns okay some
movements you know some movements again
it's a quiet day but
okay you try to take this trade here it
doesn't work out you take your loss
or you break even then you catch the
next move
right 62 all the way up into the 80s
um then you're done for the day you
don't have to trade this nonsense back
and forth later
when you could if you're a scalper
but you know you catch those moves just
like that
all day long right here here
you know those are those moves as a
trader you like to get
so again um
yeah this is a new indicator there's
going to be more this is sort of like an
impromptu
session today um but if you're
interested in it it's called flows
driver
okay and you just go to
www.flows driver okay
and it takes you to this page okay
people ask you know how can i use order
flow on stocks
okay i'm not gonna get into the
different stocks but
on this page you're gonna see a lot of
explanation right you're gonna see
here's euro currency
mini dao m q silver
wheat all with the same settings right
you don't need to vary it
very you know change the settings that
much i mean
for certain markets yeah you know and i
have a user guide with this
that helps you guide you you know on
different types of markets
but stocks
okay now gme you know is just a popular
stock because you know everyone's
talking about it
but balance strength balance
swing period is enabled swing period set
to one
okay this is gme
this is tesla right the other day we had
this nice move up
27th it's a nice move up late right you
had some nice moves down
okay but those are those nice big
parabolic moves you want to catch
same settings netflix right right before
that big parabolic move up
the signs were there in the order flow
people say well yeah you had this short
hair didn't work out okay fine that's
trading
not everything is going to work out 100
right but you want to be
in the market for when that move happens
right that big parabolic move up
my favorite jp morgan got to love those
guys um
say that just because i used to work
there but
you're seeing it all in the order flow
right so whether you're stock trader or
facebook
right 27th again all these i think are
the 27th
i think jp morgan was friday but that
big move up in facebook even late in the
day that big move up
right the moves down so again
if you're interested right now we got a
special on close driver
you just click there it takes you to
paypal um
boom right there it's very simple it's a
great
tool if again depending on the type of
trader you are if you're a swing trader
or you're looking to buy and hold for a
few days yeah honestly
it's not for you but if you're a scalper
you know and you know a day trader
looking to catch some decent moves
during the day
especially at the night session let's
again take a look
at oh let's take a look at e-minis now
again i have this set as
weak as weak as possible in the sense of
you know the settings so
but i'm kind of curious i haven't looked
at it overnight tonight
or last night rather but see it's
calculating right here it runs on
ninjatrader eight it doesn't run
on um anything else right now
all right but again you could use
ninjatrader
as your basically has your charting
platform okay
so here right since the reopen last
night it was given some nice little
bullish signals for some decent scalps
you know people say well it's not much
of a move let's actually move from
you know the 07 area up to well i'll say
10 but you know oh nine a couple of
points
honestly though i haven't looked at it
since last night but look at these this
move here
right two in the morning 230 you know
the seven and a half
area down to where you get the bullish
signals at you know o2
right and getting some
more signals that just went sideways on
you let's take a look but again this is
as as
almost as as weak as setting as you can
have
this was thursday night into friday
right right before that big jump up
in here this was where the order flow
was telling you hey you know what
something's getting ready to happen
sometimes you just get moves like this
or this but then you're going to get the
moves like this
from 12 11 and a half
down to o8 right and you're going to
come a little bit of sideways activity
and back and forth up and down little
scalps in here
let's take a look at another day but
again this is what the setting turned
literally as low as as it could possibly
be
there's no refinements on it okay
not that great going on here i'll be
honest um
you know get some small price movements
up here some small price movements down
small price movements up
then you could catch a nice decent move
from
finally in here 87 all the way down to
the 80s low 80s
some movement back up here you know some
movements back down
take a look if i got another day in here
this is uh what day is this
wednesday right we reopened
okay got a bearish signal nothing
happened then bullish
again from the 90 area right up to 94.
you know this is 93 and a half
okay bearish okay it doesn't work out
you take a small loss
you can get it back on this one you
could have got something out of that
trade
could have got something out of this
trade then a little back and forth in
here
and then well the parabolic move down so
to speak
it's not as dramatic as like what you
see on during the day session but
why the participants at night are
different than the participants
during the day right but imagine you and
this is what i like about minute-based
charts is you have time
okay just because you got this big move
down
right you imagine you're getting short
in here at 97.
this is 97 right here but you got time
in here
right you got one two two bars in here
three bars to be getting short around 97
and a half 98
and then it just drops all the way down
to you know 93
and it just sort of holds in here it's a
five-point move in
two minutes okay then on the way back up
move on the way back down another move
so you can see
you know there's whether you're trading
you know equities
currencies it doesn't matter
right because the order flow is the is
the truth okay
it's it's something that
you can use now um question is crypto
can i use it on bitcoin no you can't
um partially because
well forget about the cme bitcoin
contract there's just not enough volume
in there to really give you
um anything good even that micro bitcoin
you know i'm super excited for that
micro bitcoin
i hope it does take off you know i hope
it becomes as big as
e-mini's i doubt i don't think it's
going to um
i don't even know what the chart looks
like right now i think it's mbt
i haven't looked at it in over a week um
the volume is just just not there this
is depressing actually um
what is this and well
it's a minute is it mpt
i think it is uh you know
the thing people don't realize with
exchanges um
where's micro i want
mb i got
i have it on here
anyway
uh yeah
this is the stock nvt not the futures
is a lot of times when exchange launches
a new contract they pay people to make
markets in it so it looks like there's a
lot of liquidity
you're not going to get much information
when there's
pricing jumping around like this this is
the mbt
you know even though you know there are
some signals in here
um i'd be wary of it when it trades one
contract at 55
and trades another contract at 700
and everything else is nothing it's it's
not good
the problem with ninjatrader and the
crypto exchanges is
ninja traders want to lift the freaking
finger for the crypto exchanges
because they're so heavily invested in
the futures market with ninjatrader
brokerage
that they're not really allowing these
other exchanges to feed their data into
ninjatrader which is a big mistake in my
opinion
you know people ask me you know why i
don't
you know have this good relationship
with ninjatrader anymore is because
they became so s focused on their own
brokerage that they sort of
left out a lot of other space you know
if they would make
ninjatrader available to people to hook
up to
you know another exchange like the
crypto exchange it could be great for
ninja trader but
that that's not their business plan
right now um
so that's micro bitcoin i mean can you i
mean there's signals but again i'm
always wary of markets like this where
it's just a lot of
zeros in there even if you look at the
big one the main contract
which it looks very similar in volume
wise to the small contract but
you know it's like this right a lot of
these
a lot of this it you know trades one
contract there's
two contracts there's two contracts one
contract um
and again it looks like this is a
minute-based chart but this is from 1008
to 10 15. so that's a seven minute gap
in there
right here from 9 20
9 19 then the next bar is at 9 24.
there's just not a lot going on in on
the futures contract i really wish
it would do good but um right now it's
just it's just not
um i'm doing good uh
so if you want to use ninjatrader say
you have ninjatrader because you know a
lot of people
we buy stuff like platforms
with the intention to use it and we end
up not using it
if you have ninjatrader all you gotta do
is get a data feed right you go to
kinetic iq feed
um you know are the two main ones
um or you get it from your broker right
if you already got a broker that's
giving you a data feed you could ask
them if you could hook up ninjatrader to
it depend on who your broker is
and use it as a platform right this will
run on a
free version of ninjatrader as well
right as long as you have a data feed
okay so for example right i trade in
malaysia
right i trade the um
what i trade palm oil okay so i have an
external data feed for palm oil
okay which comes from kinetic
and you know i use this there
right i mean look at this these moves
right is it's
i mean it's kind of shocking um
sometimes
you know i don't like to say training is
easy because it's not right but
you know there's certain markets that's
why i talk about you know
look at other markets that you can trade
you know based on your time zone
um you know or your trading hours
and find them i mean you know for me i
don't like again i don't like to say
training is easy
because you know i catch a nice move up
like this or nice and then a nice move
down like that then i'm done
right this for that session right yeah
you know there's times where
i start trading here i take a loss here
take a loss here but then i can catch
that move there
right i just use ninjatrader
for this market as my trading pla as not
as my platform because i have another
platform for that
um through the broker but i just use it
as my charting software
right but again this market i scalp so
i'm just
looking for 5 10 ticks on a trade
in and out in and out right but
there's terrific price movements in a
lot of markets
that you know everybody has access to
it's just whether or not you want to use
it you know
that gas right net gas is is
there's times of the year that it has
nice movements
um times a year which it's kind of
boring but again you know net gas here
like that again these settings are the
default i believe
here yeah this is two and two two and
zero but
you know if i set it at this is the
default setting two and two
type markets and balance equality um
by disabling the balance is going to
give you more signals
you know but it's still very similar
right on a holiday morning
right one or two trades it's all you
need to take
so anyway guys um i'll put the link in
the box here for you just uh just give
me a second here
uh where was it the www.flowsdriver
oh there's my chat box here
again it's just it's a nice tool
to use you know again it depends on your
trading style again if you're a very
short-term trader
yeah i highly recommend it if you're a
long-term trader looking to hold a
position overnight
no um it's not really meant for that you
can use it
on you know i've looked at it on on
five-minute charts but you know really
the whole
benefit of using order flow is to take
advantage of
what's happening right now okay
not necessarily what happened 15 minutes
ago
an hour ago so five minute chart on that
gas i mean
yeah there's a buy signal here right you
got that big move up
sell signal here a little move down a
buy signal there um
you know that gas the other day
a five minute chart okay nothing here
nothing here you know i know some people
say oh i lost here i lost here
i'm not going to take the next trade
that's you know you still got to take
the next trade you still got to trade
right then you catch the move there but
again
you know personally i just find order
flow best used on a smaller time frame
rather than a longer time frame i do
look at five minute charts as well
but most of my trading happens off of
the one minute chart or the 30 second
chart
so anyway guys i don't want to keep you
guys here much longer
um rock b
send me your email there
i don't know what you put in the chat uh
gary asks for an nq chart okay
let me just uh well nq i look
i'll be honest on enqueue i use a 30
second chart
um just because the market is
the way the market moves um
it's just too too much
i'll say too much noise but uh
i like to yeah on a 30-second chart i i
i'm very comfortable on 30-second chart
on a nasdaq
now again this is what's the setting on
here
now due to the price movement of
nasdaq i i max it out i use three and
three
um i wouldn't use a low setting because
you're going to get a lot of signals
um with the lower the setting the
highest you go is three and three
on the setting but again let's just take
a look at three and three on here
thirty second nasdaq chart here okay
this is this morning
all right 5 31.
what do you think there's some movements
there again today it was a holiday
so it's kind of quiet overnight
this is the overnight session this is
two in the european hours
okay there's a move from you know 705
area the signals are coming in here
705 all the way down to this area which
just sort of comes in here
down to 85 right a buy signal it didn't
work out
some more sell signals a buy signal um
again in the asian hours
well since the reopen sunday night you
know
it's kind of messy
this was friday's day session in the
nasdaq
see if i can make this a little smaller
so where's the cache open
cache open is right here so right before
the cache open you're getting some buy
signals
again this is a 30 second chart 30
second chart is going to be different
than a one minute chart
friday in thursday night into friday
this is how it looked
it also moves up so moves down
i think that's as far back as this chart
goes um
so anyway i
uh there will be a recording of this
i'll probably help you get it out
um today um let's see i go through a
couple more questions
uh yeah there's the promotion
price miguel is this
price it's gonna it's 369 now
the normal price is going to be 5.99
big mike thank you for this uh
what's the effect of a e-mini trading
if a robot is used by a thousand small
traders almost the same trade price well
obviously if everyone's trying to enter
at the same trade price not everyone's
going to get in
get in it at the same price you know if
you're using limit orders
if you are using a market order yeah
everyone's going to get in and
everyone's going to be chasing the
markets um
but to be honest there's not gonna be a
thousand users using this
anyway but again you know the thing with
order flow
right when you understand order flow you
understand you know the basic concept
of big traders when they're trying to
execute they don't think in terms of
order flow they think of
am i going to move the market and if i
start moving the market or other traders
going to jump in after me
right and if they got a position they
want to get in
quickly they don't want to move the
price that much but sometimes they get
sloppy
right it's going to show up in the order
flow right and you can
pick it up and take advantage of it
okay so you know just because you have
more people reading the order flow
that's not necessarily a bad thing
right that's a good thing because you
have more people trading in
your direction now does it work for
stock option contracts i don't trade
stock options
yeah you can use it for stocks
you know for example like i i was just
showing you guys earlier
um you know the different stocks it's on
it's on the close driver
home page um you can take a look at
right
it's it's then you just trade your
options off there i mean there's so many
different types of option strategies
that you can do right now
you know even in the futures you got um
weekly options you got very short term
options that you can
that you can trade um
what's your opinion about equilibrium
point between supply and demand
well you know sometimes people get so
caught up in supply and demand
they sort of overlook really what's
happening in front of them
right i mean supply and demand doesn't
always hold
right we always like to think that you
know when i'm talking about supply and
demand levels which turn into
sport resistance levels okay now there's
true supply and demand
which is used by you know
the really big traders okay in the sense
of you know they got access to
information about what's growing in the
fields or what's shipping around the
world
and you know they got a better grasp on
it than you and i are ever going to have
when we could draw our alliance or
spline demand lines on a chart
but that doesn't mean anything because
we we are still missing out a lot of
information we're just thinking in terms
of support and resistance
and eventually they don't always hold
right they're going to they're going to
break
um and it's going to find a new level
to trade now the last question
um taj what's your
thought process for determining take
profit level well
i have an automatic you know whenever i
trade
there's always a atm attached to it with
a stop
predefined stop predetermined take
profit
and if it just goes to the take profit
immediately before i could adjust it
okay fine
but if i'm reading what's happening in
the order flow for example
like well let's just go back to
well like here okay if i'm short here at
98 okay we'll just call it 98
and i've got a three point take profit
here
at 95 okay boom i'm short at 98 my stop
is also three points i tend to keep my
my stop
a decent level away um i always adjust
it closer
um once it's in but i always got to have
something in because you never know as
soon as you get into a trade
you don't know if the joker over at
goldman sachs has got his finger on a
button to sell you know to buy 3 000
right after i get short okay so you
gotta have a stop in there
and take profit because sometimes the
markets just
move instantly right and i do want to
participate yeah i would have loved to
adjust it down to 93 and got more out of
the trade
but i know i got to be happy with my
initial take profit so that's why i have
an initial take profit and if i see the
market
in this case it just sort of dropped
right down to it okay fine i'm fine with
that
but if i see the market sort of you know
sometimes you see it like here where it
sort of goes up
sort of goes hangs around sideways and
then makes the next push up
you know getting long at you know 96
and a half in here this is 96 and a half
right
the bullish order flows in here so
you're getting a 97 we'll call it 97.
i gotta take profit at 4 200 but it goes
from
97 two points up to 99 it's just sort of
going in here
yeah i back it up to 01 maybe 02
you know back it up a point so you know
and based on
but it's based on what's happening in
the order flow sometimes it just goes
directly to your take profit
or to your stop but you don't have time
to change it
okay but if i still see a grinding
higher
building up ahead of steam in the order
flow then i'm going to
to give it a little bit more space now
there's times where i get fancy and i
adjust myself out of my normal profits
times where i literally
would oh you know it's like i'm long
from 97
i got my take profit at
4 200. um how i'm going to adjust it up
to 03
okay well it doesn't get up to 03.
next thing i know i tried to sell twos
miss it try to sell ones miss it
then i'm back down the to double o
hopefully i get it otherwise i gotta
just get out at the market and
you know i finessed myself out of the
market that happens um
it's unfortunate but you know it happens
and i should just kept my
initial take profit in but um you know
but if i see something in the order fill
it's very
conducive to my position yeah i will
adjust it but at the same time it can
move very fast
that you might miss it say you know
say this move down here sort of grinding
you know you move it from 95
down to 93 okay that's good but if you
move it down to
um you know say yeah you go i'm gonna go
down to 91
or 90. it only comes down to 91 and a
quarter you're
you're screwed okay yeah hopefully you
can cover it up in here at 93
94 which is still below your 95 area
that's good enough
but if it makes that push down towards
your take your new adjusted take profit
it doesn't hit it try and cover it as
quickly as possible
um but anyway guys the link is in the
chat there
check it out you know i said it i'm sure
it's going to be helpful to a lot of
people
order flows flows drivers just www
dot flows driver
it's very simple nothing fancy
in terms of the link just
closedriver.com i said we have the
special
price right now normally it's
after this promotional period right now
it's just 369.
just scroll down here i mean it's
normally it's gonna be 5.99
you know i create a lot of these tools
to replace what you're seeing
again not everybody wants to use a
footprint chart right i get that
all right and not everybody
um you know wants to spend the time to
understand what's happened on the
footprint chart
that's why i create tools like this to
sort of replace what
you know the analysis that you're going
to be doing on a footprint chart
so you can see it on your screen you
know again people are asking about
stocks here's
you know gme here's tesla
netflix jpmorgan facebook right
but again if you're trading stocks you
want to trade stocks that have good
volume
all right and it's easy to check which
stocks have good volume just go to a
trading view and
punch up you know sort by stocks with
them you know the most active
right the most volume um there so
again the normal price is 5.99 but you
can get it right now it's just 369.
so thanks everybody for you know
spending this morning with me
it's uh it's memorial day it's a holiday
so
enjoy the rest of the day and you know
thank you for your service the ones that
have uh
served you know appreciate it for giving
us the freedom that we have
so enjoy the rest of your day and bye
bye
you